When the Berlin wall fell, there was an
American State Department official named
Francis Fukayama
and he wrote a very influential essay
called the end of history.
And for decades,
capitalism was in a struggle with
communism.
And in his essay, Fukuyama argued that
with the triumph of capitalism, we've
come to the end of history. Meaning, we
now know what humanity most strives for,
which is a liberal consumer democracy
where people feel empowered to have the
freedom to buy whatever they want. And
this for him was the apex of human
civilization.
And this creates what is called the
unipolar moment where America
is the global hedgeimon. And it creates
a world that is heavily glo globalized,
capitalistic
um and very individualistic. And this is
a very unique moment in human history.
And we've come with this one I ran to
the end of this moment. All right. So
let me first explain the three major
characteristics of this unipolar moment.
The first is what I call PAX Americana
where American power American military
might guarantee peace in the entire
world. And this is unique in human
history where for the first time there
was a power that was able to dominate
the entire globe and America was able to
do so through three mechanisms. Okay.
The first is of course its military
power but but specifically aerial
supremacy.
Okay, which is backed up by special
forces
and the CIA.
So the CIA was able to infiltrate every
single government in the world and
identify who would be loyal to the
American Empire and then promote this
person. If there are individuals that
challenged the American Empire, these
people were demoted or eliminated.
nations that prove problematic for
example maybe Syria or Libya spe special
forces went in to sabotage the economy
and then aerero power went in destroy
the government and um so this past
Americana now what's good about this is
that it did bring peace to very
problematic regions for example in in
East Asia
Japan South Korea North Korea China
Vietnam um to not compete against each
other. They just participate in global
economy which brought tremendous wealth
and prosperity to uh the East Asia
region. This is true also in Europe uh
and South America as as well. Okay. So
um a supremacy then you have something
called surveillance
and basically what I mean by that is the
internet.
So believe it or not, but the internet
was created not not to actually help you
communicate and to watch pornography.
was actually to to have um a mass
surveillance system over the entire
human population so that the Pentagon
the military knew exactly the vibe or
the culture uh the attitudes the
emotions of each region and through
social media through mechanisms such as
Facebook and Twitter they were able to
manipulate certain uh emotions. Okay. So
the second mechanism is mass
surveillance through the publicization
of the internet.
Um and the third is something called a
rulesbased international order.
Okay. And what this means is American
power hid behind multilateral
organizations such as the uh United
Nations such as the World Bank, such as
the World Trade Organization. And so
people didn't notice that the American
mil empire was dominating everything.
They believed that the world was fair
and just and through uh logic and reason
and debate they could present their
case. All right. So for the longest
time, Miss Pasameana provided peace and
stability to the world which brought
tremendous prosperity.
All right. So that's number one. Number
two is the supremacy of science.
So for most of human history
people were religious they believed in
gods but
with the rise of past americanana
science became the dominant religion of
the whole world. All right so
the last example is co
co was raging across the world and then
they introduce vaccines. Now I teach
crude thinking skills. So when I first
heard about vaccines I was a bit
skeptical. I said to my friends who are
Chinese and American I said you know um
vaccines used to take about 10 years to
develop and that's when the virus is
stable and have been around for
centuries but this co is constantly
mutating and they haven't have have done
enough trial research. So, is it really
safe to take this these vaccines? And
whether they were Chinese or American,
their response was the same, which is,
"How dare you question science? You are
a peasant. Have you gone to school? Have
you know culture?
Can you not think?" Okay. And this shows
you the how science has become the new
religion
of the world. And if you think about it,
these scientists that run the world,
they're actually transnational priests.
Okay? And science is an international
brotherhood. Where if you're a scientist
in China, you're not you're not actually
loyal to China. You're actually loyal to
the international order of science
because that's how you get promoted,
right? You get published in nature or
science. If you win an award like no
Nobel prize, that's how how you get
rewarded. Okay? So, you're better off
being loyal to the brotherhood
brotherhood of science rather than your
own nation state. And of course, it is
the American Empire that controls
science. And the third um unique aspect
of the Europole moment is of course the
universality
of the US dollar.
And it's incredible thing. Think about
where just a piece of paper
you think it's gold. You think there's
value in it and not just you but
everyone around you. So that if you take
your US dollars, you know anyone in the
world and buy yourself a villa or uh
enjoy a nice vacation or fly around. But
not only that, but you aspire your life
to accumulate as much US dollars as
possible, right? Is there really a
difference between $100 million and $100
billion? There's actually no difference.
You can't spend it. But you want to
achieve as much as possible and as a
result you um focus your entire life on
accumulating as much as possible. Okay.
So these are the three main pillars of
the unipolar movement. And again in the
beginning which was maybe the early 90s
this led to tremendous peace and
prosperity throughout the world. The
problem though is that over time these
three pillars started to decay. Right?
So um past Americana started to itself
ignore the rules national order which
itself created.
Right? So America started to bomb
countries such as uh Libya and Syria
without in actual approval.
Most recently it went to attack Iran
without even asking for the opinion of
the world without even caring what the
what the world thought. Okay. So this
leads to the idea of hubris.
Maybe the first generation appreciates
the importance of collaboration
of consensus but the second generation
the children are arrogant they have
hubris they want to enjoy their power
okay so that's problem number one
supremacy of science um uh religion
basically it becomes a religion in
itself orthodoxy
so that science does not become the main
engine of innovation in the world it
becomes becomes the main engine of
orthodoxy or suppression. That's why for
the past 20 30 years we've seen very
little in terms of technological
innovation. Don't tell me Silicon Valley
is a center of innovation in the world.
Okay? All they do is make food delivery
apps. It's been a long time since we've
seen massive innovation in the world.
What we've seen these past 20 30 years
is the scaling out the popularization of
innovation right where American
technology is spread throughout the
world especially in China but we have
not seen actually major innovation in
science itself right and the third thing
the university of the US dollar leads to
um printing
dollars okay or just basically
corruption where because America America
is able to print as much US dollars as
it wants to fund its corruption.
It does so. Okay. So, the US dollar has
has lessened in value. And what this
means is basically it's made inequality
worse. It's made corruption worse. It's
made people very lazy. Because if you're
a young person, you're like, you know
what? No matter how hard I work, I'm
still screwed in the end because the
boomers, the older generation, have so
much more money than I do. I can never
catch up. So I I refuse to play this
game. Either I refuse to play this game,
so I quite quit, you know, comp life
flat or I gamble. I pray that if I put a
million dollars in Bitcoin, it'll go up
to $10 million or or or the stock market
or sports betting. Okay, that's why uh
in America, gambling has become so
popular.
All right. So this has led to uh today
basically. All right. So um it's we
shouldn't see this war against Iran as
just a decision of one person Donald
Trump or the massations of a country
Israel. Really this war in Iran is
happening because we come to the end of
the unipolar moment because uh the
American empire has become corrupt,
self-indulgent, lazy, arrogant.
All right. So with the end of the
American empire, with the end of Paxana,
we are shifting towards a new world. And
this new world, some will survive, most
will not. Okay? Because and this is true
throughout history where when empire
declines and the world order is shifting
where there's a paradigm shift people
are forced to make a hard choice of
either adapt or die. All right. So let
me show you what how how the world needs
to change if it is to survive. Basically
what has happened is we have to move
from an emphasis on efficiency
to
resilience.
Okay, that is the main
goal in the future. Today it's really
about how to make things as cheap as
possible and get get it to as many
people as quickly as possible to make as
much money as possible. Okay. The idea
of efficiency,
generating as much profit as possible,
the idea of resilience is is to
appreciate that there will be a series
of crises and what you need to do is
focus on adapting and surviving these
crises. Okay. So, for a nation, for a
community to survive in the future,
there has to be three major changes. And
if you're able to make these three um
major changes, you will survive. If you
do not make these changes, you will be
eliminated. Okay? It will be survival of
fittest.
All right? So the first thing you need
to do is move from materialism
to spirituality.
Right now the entire world these nation
states have convinced the population
what matters is your material
well-being.
If you are driving a car, if you have a
house, if you have enough food to eat,
then you should shut up and obey because
we're doing your job. Okay? But in the
future, governments can't do that
because there's not enough resources to
go around. They feel differently has to
make you believe that what matters is
your happiness, your well-being, your
spirituality and that that usually means
um a renewed focus on religion. Okay,
that's the first thing. Second thing is
to move from a system of individuality
to community
and family. All
right. And what this means is today what
you're taught in school, what you're
taught society is what matters is you
me. Okay. The ego if if it's doing well
for me, it's good. I don't actually care
about other people. In the future, you
have to focus on building a community on
helping others.
Okay. And the last
um um uh major shift is from the old to
the young. Okay. And this is very simple
and this is actually the hardest thing
to do which is like today most countries
especially the wealthy western
industrial nations are controlled by the
baby boomers, the elderly, the
gerontocracy.
They have all the money, they have all
the power.
But for starting to thrive in the
future, this power need to shift to a
younger generation. Ideally, maybe in
the 30s. Okay? The younger the better.
And you think this is easy to do. It's
not because first of all, these baby
boomers have access to the best
healthcare in the world. They have a lot
of money and they really enjoy living
and they're also really selfish. Okay,
so this is actually the hardest problem
to solve for most western societies. How
do you transfer power from the old to
the young? And quite honestly,
historically, we've never ever faced
this problem before. Never. Because the
old simply don't live that long. Okay?
Now, babys are living to at least 100
years old. So, they stay another 20
years ahead of them in power.
Meanwhile, the young cannot
uh develop the experience and expertise
in order to lead the nation. So,
whichever nation actually figures out
this problem first, how do you the old
and give power to the young then will
most likely thrive in the new world
that's coming? And if you were if you
were to ask me which nation would most
likely achieve this first, I would say
Japan. And the reason is very simple.
because Japan in Japan this problem is
the most present. They are the um um the
eldest population they have the oldest
population in the world and so they they
need to resolve this issue really really
quickly okay in maybe in the five next 5
10 years um and I think that Japan will
actually resolve this issue but
>> it may be the only nation that's able to
resolve this issue because it's so
difficult.
>> You love your grandparents. Do you want
to see your grandparents die? Of course
not. Okay. You're going against human
biological nature. All right. Okay. All
right. So, that's the main argument I
want to make you to today. Okay. So,
what we're going to do now is we're
going to look at how the world is going
to transform because of what's happening
in the circle moves because of this war
in uh Iran. Okay. All right. So
basically, we're in a new world because
our world today is built entirely
entirely on access to cheap petroleum
products, cheap energy, right? Why are
why are you allowed to be in school
learning from me rather than the fields
farming? Because of energy, right?
Because of oil from the Middle East.
Your computer is based on what?
>> Petroleum.
This camera filming is based on what?
Petroleum. This pad petroleum. This
clothing petroleum. The medicine you eat
petroleum. The food that you eat comes
from fertilizers which is based also on
petroleum. So basically everything in
this room everything in the world is
based on cheap petroleum. The entire
global economy the main foundation is
cheap petroleum. So what happens in a
world where petroleum is cheap? Well,
now you have a you need a massive
rebalancing in the world. Okay. The
other thing about the world is this is
the GCC countries. Okay. um uh the
Middle East countries. And as you can
see, this is really important to see is
um around the year 2005,
they started to
have massive
massive
um account surplus, meaning they were
selling so much oil they couldn't really
spend all their money. Do you guys know
why? What? Why was this happening? What
happened in 2005, 2004 that made these
countries extremely wealthy?
All right, China. Okay,
think about it. What's China doing?
Well, China in the 80s and '90s was
putting factories, right? But then China
setting up this account surplus. So now
China wants to develop its industrial
base, right? And how do you do that? by
importing
oil
from the GCC,
right? And that's why we have these
skyscrapers, these malls, these roads,
okay? Because China was able to import
all this cheap oil from the GCC. And
then the GCC would take this money,
okay, and then invest it back into the
American stock market. But not just
that, but they would invest it in
Africa. They would in invest in
infrastructure. So for the longest time
the Chinese economy and the GCC are the
two main pillars
of the entire global economy.
Okay. And what this means is that if the
GCC no longer is able to uh export oil,
this have a major impact on China and
together the two are going to have a
major impact on the globe economy. Okay.
Basically the glob economy is dead. All
right. Okay. Another thing that you may
not be aware of is today flying around
the world. It's very very simple to do.
You get like if you want it, what we can
do now is get our mobiles out. Uh go to
a website and look at where we're going
to fly to and then book that flight for
tonight. Pay using a credit card, take a
taxi to the airport, get on a flight,
and we're there the next morning. That's
really really impressive. Guess what
guys? You couldn't do this 20 years ago.
Okay, the technology was around but it
was not um widely available. Now look at
this where the entire world is
interconnected. Okay. Um this is a
pretty stark chart where in 1950 it was
considered an a tremendous luxury to
fly. You had to be a millionaire
basically to want to fly for vacation.
Okay. everyone else just drove the car.
Now it's like anyone can drive and again
this happened just in the past basically
30 40 years and this of course is
because of past Americana where pass
Americana will guarantee there's no
problem in the world and therefore
planes can just fly around otherwise be
shot down. Okay.
All right. Well, this world is coming to
an end. In the future, flights will be
very expensive and vacations will be
unaffordable. Okay?
All right.
This is the internet, guys. Yeah. You
don't know this. You think that the
internet is just that you go on the
computer and then boom, the internet is
there. No, actually, the internet is
underseas cables that connect the entire
world. And unfortunately,
uh, there's a war going on right here,
guys. And unfortunately, it's really
easy for Iran to cut off the underseas
cables, which would lead to internet
disruption for maybe 20 30% of the
world. Okay? African Africa, India, the
Middle East, maybe parts of Europe would
lose internet access. You think, okay,
well, that's fine. They just won't watch
Nick Netflix anymore. No guys. Okay. The
entire economy is based off the cloud.
So if you want to bank, if you want
basically fi finance, okay, this had a
huge impact in the world and this could
happen any time where for whatever
reason there's a war going on in a
certain moves, some cables get get cut
off and suddenly you've lost internet
access and this would basically
cause major um disruptions throughout
the world.
All right.
Okay. So, one thing that you notice
about this world is the sheer amount of
population growth where after World War
II because of Pax Americana, you see a
massive boom in population.
And unfortunately,
this is not sustainable. It is not
possible for the planet to sustain 8
billion people, many of whom want to fly
around the world every uh twice a year,
who want to drive an SUV, who want to
have food any who want to avocados
uh every single day, they want to have
like cherries every single day. Okay.
So,
um this population growth
um is not sustainable and basically what
happens is this when you are too
offbalance when there's a correction the
correction is pretty extreme. Okay. So
this truck by itself the fact that we
have so many people means like if
there's a crisis
the population will see a massive
shrinkage. Okay. You're like, "Okay,
how?" And the answer is food scarcity.
Food is not is today pretty common. But
food is based on global trade. Okay. So,
let me show you what I mean by this. All
right. So, this the the yellow, okay,
are places that need fertilizer to grow
food, meaning their land is not uh good
for farming. So needed fertilizer to
grow food. They also have a large
population. As you can see, a lot of
this is based in uh Africa and maybe
Central Asia and parts of South America.
Ammonia is here produced from oil to
petroleum that is fundamental for
fertilizers. And as you can see, this is
mainly in the north of the world. What
allows for a young people is the fact
that the north is able to export
fertilizer to the south and that's it
guys you understand if this were to stop
for the reason people in the south would
be in a lot of trouble
right so as you can see
this trade in fertilizer is what
sustains a global population of 8
billion people. Again, if there's a
disruption to this trade, the people in
the south are in a lot of trouble.
All right?
So, um if you're in the green, you're
okay. Okay? But if you are in the red,
you you are in a lot of trouble. Okay?
you are in a lot of trouble if you are
if you are in
the
red. But honestly, if you are not in the
green, you could still be in a lot of
trouble because again, what we're
looking for is resilience.
The idea of efficiency is let's imagine
the best case scenario and try to make
as much money out of it as possible.
Okay. The idea of resilience is let's
imagine the worst case scenario and see
if you can survive it.
Basically, if you are if you have food
security issues,
you are facing a massive problem. Okay?
Because again, we're imagine the worst
case scenario. And again, I hate to say
this, but if you're not in the green,
you should be worrying right now. Okay?
And and where's China?
Not in the green, guys. Okay?
It's something that national leaders in
the world have us talking about right
now. Food scarcity.
All right.
Water.
Again,
the countries that suffer from food
scarcity,
some of them also suffer from food
scarcity. Okay. From water water
scarcity.
Okay. All right. Forget this. All right.
Okay. So, basically this area is a lot
of trouble. I would say that water is
far more problematic than food. And
again, I hate to say this, but if you
are any country
here,
what is going on here?
If you're any country in this area,
okay, you should be worried.
Freedom is a very important issue
because freedom is actually important
for resilience issues. Okay. And what
this means is that when there's a
crisis, leaders and the population need
to collectively make sacrifices.
But when there's very little freedom,
meaning there's very little transparency
and accountability, where the public
don't have access to the leadership,
then the leadership could possibly make
selfish, self-defeating decisions
and it and the public is not involved
and therefore the public refuses to make
the sacrifices necessary in order to uh
make the nation survive. Okay?
And so this leads to conflict around the
world. And again, countries that um
suffer the most from food issues and
water issues also are most likely to
come into conflict
with other people. Okay. So this is a
map of nations at war. The red means
that they are at war. Okay. And you can
see Africa in the Middle East is uh
especially
under a lot of conflict and a lot of
stress while at the same time they're
suffering from food scarcity and water
issues.
Right? So
what you will see uh sorry another issue
I want to u bring up is the idea of mega
cities and the idea mega cities is any
cities that have over 10 million people
and you think wow like spaces are
amazing cuz you have like shopping malls
and you have like skyscrapers that's
great no no guys mega cities
are really bad okay mega cities should
not exist. They exist because of
globalization.
Because what many cities do is they're
able to bring in a lot of people, have
them specialize in a particular area,
make it industrial, and then export it
to to the rest of the world. Okay? And
where are most mega cities located?
Well, they're located in India and in
China.
That's a problem because India and China
both suffer from food and water issues.
If you are to be resilient, you actually
want most your population not in cities
but in the countryside growing food
because first of all they are
self-sufficient. Second of all, you will
have um a food supply. Unfortunately,
right now um China imports a quarter of
its food. And also remember food also
requires energy to grow right so China
imports 75% of its oil.
This brings up the question of how
resilient is China. Okay but not just
China but also any big country with a
mega city or too many mega cities India
um specifically will face problems in
the future.
Again, if you're a national leader, you
should be worried right now. Okay.
All right.
So,
with this war and disruptions to global
trade, we should expect massive in
instability in nations that are not very
resilient, okay? That have very little
freedom,
that have food issues, and which have
water issues, okay? And so you would see
revolutions, you would see wars, you
would see famines which leads to what?
Which leads to massive migration. Okay?
And so these are trends. These are
migration trends that we're already
seeing where people from Africa, Middle
East are moving to Europe and people
from um South America and Latin America
are moving to the United States. Okay?
And we should expect these trends to not
only continue but to accelerate by maybe
a 100 times.
Okay?
And you think to yourself, okay, well,
what Europe and North America can do is
just build walls, right? They should
right now build a wall because you're
going to see a massive influx of
refugees due to uh food and water
issues.
And unfortunately
Europe and America have a huge problem.
And the problem of course is aging.
Okay. So in 2020 the countries
in purple are countries that have a
significant elderly population.
And this is 2050 where the entire
northern hemisphere will have
um an significant elderly population. So
the north the industrial economies are
aging very rapidly which means their
only option is to bring in cheap
desperate
workers from the south who are fleeing
conflict zones
in order to
um run their economies. Right? The
problem is this of this of course is
that this will lead to cultural conflict
where the local populations, native
populations will feel they're being
replaced by
um these refugees and these immigrants
and this will probably lead to civil
conflict within
uh North America and within
Europe.
Okay. And unfortunately,
there's really no way around
this issue
because the elderly are in control and
they want people to mow their lawns.
They want people to nourish them. They
want people to deliver food to them. And
unfortunately,
young people don't have to do that
because their parents have money. Okay?
So one way around this issue is by
importing cheap immigrant labor,
right?
Okay.
With the end of Pax Americana, what you
will see emerge is regional trading
blocks. Bas basically the idea of
mercantileism. Okay.
mercantalism.
And for most of human history, this was
what we did where there was no one power
that controlled the entire world. What
happened was that maybe you had a local
hedgeimon which guaranteed trade um
among its allies. Okay? And you didn't
trade with other people. You only traded
within your regional trading block. And
that's the world we're heading back
towards. Okay? So this is a a map of the
17 16th century 17th century where you
know you have these mercury empires like
the British, the Portuguese, the French
uh the Spanish and they had their own
trade networks and they refused to work
with each other but the system worked
fine. Okay, it's more expensive. It was
not so convenient but it still works. So
this this does not mean the end of
global trade. It just means much more
limited global trade, right?
Um another thing that you will notice
about the Asian economies is slaves.
Slaves were a very important part of the
trade. And the reason why is this.
You need energy to run society. Today we
use oil. Back then they use human
beings, right? you can no longer have
access to cheap oil. What you do is you
enslave people
and that's the way historically we've
done things. All right? Okay.
So the last thing I want to talk about
is religion because remember the idea of
resilience is you need people to focus
more on spirituality and less on
materialism because if they focus on
materialism their lives are getting
worse and worse. Okay? So you need to
cause a national spiritual rejuvenation
in your country.
And if you are in the gray
um you might have issues. Okay? Why?
Because your people are not religious
and too materialistic. And
unfortunately,
East Asia, okay, Japan,
uh,
China, Korea,
Vietnam are especially
non-religious. That's been a problem for
them in the future. Okay. All right. So,
let's just summarize what we've learned
so far. What are some major trends that
we should expect over the next 10 10 20
years? Again, I just say this. All
right. If you really believe that next
week Donald Trump and Iran are going to
come to peace agreement, if you believe
that um maybe in five 6 months both Iran
and the United States will exhaust
themselves, the global economy will
suffer too much and then they'll just
stop the war and things will go back to
normal. I don't know. I don't know what
to tell you. Okay, you're living in a
fantasy world. You have to wake up and
recognize that this is the end of the
unipolar moment. We're moving towards a
new world. And you have to choose to
adapt to this new world or you will die.
It's that simple. All right. So massive
trend is de-industrialization
and dearization
where people in the cities will have to
move back to the countryside especially
young people. Okay? Okay, they have to
learn like real skills. No more
cryptocurrency trading for you guys,
okay? Learn how to milk a cow or kill a
chicken or go, whatever, okay? But just
do something useful for your life. Um,
nationalism and rematurization is very
important where you have to get young
people who willing to fight and defend
your land. Okay? And that means getting
them to believe that your nation
deserves to be strong. So whichever
nations are most ready and most able to
excite their younger population in
fighting wars will will be the ones who
will be most resilient.
Uh systems basically independent
training blocks
resource wars is a very big thing. Okay.
Famines, genocides, slavery. Okay. So
remember from most of human history,
humans were the cheap entity. If you
don't have access to cheap oil, well
then you're going to enslave human
beings. All right? This is not a pretty
future, but it is a future that could
happen and you have to mentally prepare
yourself for this possibility. Okay. uh
mass migration where people in the south
are most likely to suffer from resource
wars over water and food and and people.
So they escape and escape to Europe and
North America.
Okay. Um revolution, civil wars, and
political instability in America and in
Europe because
the baby boomers refuse to retire from
the scene. And these are aging
populations, massive inequality, massive
corruption, massive sagy. And so this
will lead to chaos in the streets. Okay.
Um, religion is a big thing.
Um, if you are not religious, I actually
recommend looking into the possibility
of becoming a religion. Okay? It's going
to be very useful for what's going to
happen later on. Um this these are
things I will talk about more in the
future. Okay. But I will bring them up
now like how I see the world in 10 20
years time. All right. So I will say
this I think that there will be
eventually an alliance between Russia
and Germany in Europe.
Maybe for the next 5 10 years Germany
and Russia will go to war against each
other. But eventually what the two will
figure out is they both are actually
working together and fighting against
each other. Okay. Um you have P Judeica.
Remember the entire point of this war in
Iran from Israel's perspective is to
knock out America from the Middle East
and establish up as the local hegemon
and then becomes past Judeaica.
Okay. So I think Israel will come to
dominate the Middle East. But then
you're like, "What about Iran?" Okay.
And like I know this is hard to
understand, but if the United States
were to leave the scene and Israel and
Iran had to go to war against each
other, what would happen is they would
say, "Why?"
Because Israel is like, "I don't want
Persia." And then Iran is like, "I don't
want Israel." And Israel has nuclear
weapons. So they would agree to split
the Middle East out where Iran controls
Humus and Israel controls the Levant.
Right? Historically actually um the
Israelis, the Jewish people, they hated
the Greeks, they hate the Romans, but
they actually had the Persians. So
there's this history going back where
where Persians and Jews actually get
along very well. And in fact, um, in the
Middle East, the place outside Israel
with the largest Jewish population is
Iran. And they're very well treated
there. Okay? So, I don't see why if
America were to leave the scene, why why
couldn't Israel and Iran come to a
mutually satisfactory agreement benefits
both nations, right? Um, Japan
again I think the major problem facing
all western industrial nations is the
aging crisis. What do you do with these
people who are 90 years old? They can't
get out of the house. Their brains
aren't really functioning properly, but
they still control all the money, all
the power, and they're extremely
influential. What do you do?
Well, in most countries, you can't do
anything about it. But Japan is a very
special country where the elderly have a
more obligation to the nation, to the
people. So, it could be u a situation
where Japan is in a lot of trouble and
the elderly voluntarily
choose to exit power and give it to the
young. All right. But I think Japan's
the only nation that would do this
voluntarily. Every other nation um
basically basically there has to be wars
in order for the young to arise to
power. All right. Uh the American Holy
Empire.
The nation that is most capable of
surviving
the next few decades of tribulation of
crisis is America. Why? America is so
incredibly incredibly wealthy. Okay,
it's protected by two oceans. It really
controls Canada and Mexico. So think of
America as not just the continent
continent of America but really has
entire North American and Latin
American. Okay, that entire sphere is
basically America. So it has unlimited
resources. It has unlimited population
and also America and the Americans are
the most creative, the most
entrepreneurial, the most the most
energetic people in the world. So I
would bet against America. All right.
But what I think will happen is that
America will need a new identity in
order to survive the age of tribulation.
they will go from past Judea sorry past
Americana which is a secular global
um idea to one that is much more
nationalistic that is more focused on
community and nation that means
embracing Christianity. Okay. And I
think that Christianity is will be the
force that rebuilds America after um the
many crisis America will face over next
few years. The last thing that will
happen is techno Marxarism. Okay. Where
nations that
um have the resources want to institute
an AI surveillance state to better
marshall the limited resources
um to basically basically to better
control its people. Okay. And this
something we'll talk about later on.
Okay. Um but basically you will have
this sharp uh division of people into
different classes where at the very top
you have freedom but people at the very
bottom um become slaves or surfs. Right?
Okay. So that is it for trends I see in
the future. Again, I hate to say this,
but you have to give the illusion that
this war will end soon and that once
this war ends, then we'll go back to the
things before this the before this war.
Okay? No, the world has completely
changed.
We're not going back to the old world.
We're going to a new world. And what
this new world will look like is
something that we can choose to control.
Okay?
All right. Any questions?
All right.
So about the new world, so the
relationships between countries will all
be changed such as China and Japan and
you know those five big countries will
the waters be changed?
>> Okay.
All right. So the best way to understand
the geopolitical situation is that is
it's constantly in flux. It's constantly
dynamic. Okay? Meaning you cannot easily
divide nation states into enemies
anymore. Their alliances will constantly
shift over time and the nation state
system will also break apart into uh
much more resilient communities. That's
it's possible that nation states become
a series of city states. Okay. So um
basically think about the world the
world in maybe the 1930s
or maybe even China during the war and
states period. Okay. Basically I can't
tell you that we'll go to a new world
and then this is what it will look like.
No it will constantly change over time.
Okay? alliance will constantly shift
over time. It's possible that in the
beginning um in East Asia maybe Vietnam,
Japan, South Korea, United States,
Russia combined to contain China because
they see China as the hedgeimog. But
then they're like, "Wait a wait a minute
here. Japan's rising in power, so let's
combine against Japan." Okay, it's a
dynamic situation. But but basically
what you have to understand is that
everything that you've been taught in
school, everything that you understand
about the world, everything you believe
about to be true about the world will
change. And so you have to open your
mind and be ready for constant um
political flux.
Okay? Does that make sense?
All right. Any any more questions, guys?
All right. So um now that we've looked
at the world ahead for the next 10, 20,
50 years, who who knows who knows how
long, um what I want to do next, class,
is examine how this this war between
United States and Iran will eventually
end.